take a brief moment to think back to
your younger years spending long
tiresome hours trapped in a classroom
waiting to hear the noise of that final
bell of the day that sound meant freedom
the end of another grueling six hours at
your desk and the chance to get back to
the warm sanctuary of home if you were
lucky you might not have had to go far
to get back to the safety and security
of being in your parents house living
close enough to the school would mean
you could easily walk home when the day
was through but your classmates well
they weren't all as lucky some of them
had miles to travel all the way across
town even fortunately though the school
bus would always be waiting outside at
the end of each day ready to take a
gaggle of rowdy kids back home and if
you were one of those kids that had to
take the bus you'll know that the trip
home after school was hardly a calm
drive paper planes and spit balls firing
from all directions wads of chewing gum
stuck to the undersides of seats other
kids all around you screaming and
yelling at the top of their lungs still
it could be worse right no
trust us it could be much much worse
than you can ever imagine what if one
day the bus that picked you up from
school wasn't a bus at all what if
instead it was scp-2086
picture this one day you get put in
detention at school maybe you were
disrupting a class or were caught
spraying graffiti on the outside wall of
the gym whatever the reason we're sure
you'll think it is unfair that you got
held back after school after everyone
else had already gone home but you do
your time until finally you're told you
can leave problem is your house is on
the other side of town and you've
already missed the bus you make your way
off the campus down the nearest street
maybe there's a city bus you can catch
that'll get you back home as you stroll
away from your school you realize that
the nearest bus stop the first one on
the route home seems to be further away
than you remember it being must be just
the exhaustion of a long day getting the
better of you playing tricks on your
mind it's not like someone could move
the bus stop right finally reaching the
stop you noticed lights coming down the
street after a few moments of waiting
quietly a late bus just like you hoped
for it pulls up to the next stop the
doors folding open to allow you on board
it's totally empty save for the driver
but straight away you notice there's
something odd about him he seems drained
of color his movements are weird more
like a puppet on strings than an actual
living breathing human being now that
you think about it if it wasn't for the
fact he was clearly moving driving the
bus you might assume that he was a
corpse then again maybe he just had a
long day too taking a seat you try not
to think about it and stare out of the
window in boredom you watch as the route
takes you past stop after stop all of
them empty just like the bus itself but
then something unexpected happens you've
ridden the bus to and from school so
many times before that you can't help
but notice when for some reason it takes
a wrong turn looking out the window you
know you aren't mistaken the driver has
changed direction instead of heading
towards the nearest stop to home he's
taken the bus towards the furthest edge
of town desperately you try yelling at
him asking why he's taking the wrong
turn but the driver stays still as if he
can't even hear what you're saying
that's when you notice the smell you
didn't catch it before but now it's all
around you filling the air inside the
bus it's almost like the scent of
disinfectant the bust now smells the
same way a hospital does but that's not
all the more you breathe it in the more
you feel yourself starting to get woozy
arms and legs getting heavier everything
around you feels as if it's spinning
uncontrollably out of the windows you
can just about make up the sight of a
junkyard blurring in and out of focus
it's meant to be abandoned and yet
you're sure you can see movement massive
indeterminate shape shifting around in
the dark finally your vision goes dark
and you fall unconscious onto the floor
of the bus only you were never on the
bus to begin with no although you didn't
know it you were prey to something that
just looked like a bus
scp-2086 and now that it's caught you
you'll never see the light of day again
now scp-2086 doesn't just refer to a
single creature not by a long shot it is
the designation given to an entire
species of arthropods think lobsters
crabs and spiders or insects like
centipedes and millipedes only
much bigger to the untrained eye and
depending on when you look an instance
of scp-2086 will normally look like any
ordinary public transport vehicle of any
make and model or belonging to any
company or transit authority usually
though they look like regular old buses
at least while they're out foraging for
food when born an scp-2086 specimen will
grow to full juvenile size within a week
usually weighing 200 kilograms or less
full matured adult instances however can
weigh approximately 17 000 kilograms the
adults are the ones that go out foraging
leaving the nest to collect food to then
bring back to the juvenile scp-2086
and by food we of course mean humans
while out on the roads matured scp-2086
creatures are practically identical to
the auto vehicles that form their bodies
but the materials that this disguise is
made from the steel plastic wood and
glass they're all actually comprised of
specialized chitin the kind of outer
shell you'd find on most arthropods but
underneath that outer shell that's where
you'll find the real horror within the
main chamber beneath the flooring of the
bus's long inner portion is stored the
pulsing beating heart of an
scp-2086 specimen and we don't mean that
in a metaphorical sense if you were to
lift up the floorboards of one of these
bust-like creatures you'd see its heart
along with other vital organs like the
creature's brain and stomach what's more
the figure in the front seat that you
thought was a living breathing bus
driver actually isn't living or
breathing not anymore preserved in a
shell-like substance that the creature
is able to produce the driver is
actually a human corpse acting as a
decoy for scp-2086's
from within the bus body fibrous
appendages reach up into the corpse
almost like incredibly thin hairs the
creature can then use the cadaver
essentially as a puppet a puppet with a
dead person's body that's how an
scp-2086 is able to move its driver
around making it appear more lifelike so
it can lure its prey aboard think of it
like the bioluminescent light that an
anglerfish uses to tempt unsuspecting
fish into their jaws same principle but
with a dramatically different result
when it comes to scp-2086
but if you thought bus creatures with
internal organs under the floor and dead
meat puppets in the driver's seat
weren't creepy enough there's still much
more to
scp-2086's than meets the eye for
example when they aren't out foraging
the adult creatures can unravel the roof
of their bust-shaped outer shell
underneath is a pair of wings large
enough and strong enough to carry their
entire 7 000 kilos of weight off the
ground and up into the air as for eyes
the headlights at the front are in
actual fact bioluminescent optical
organs allowing the creatures to see
their prey even in the dark still not
horrifying enough well would knowing
about their legs help the wheels
underneath an scp-2086 specimen are also
capable of unraveling forming long gray
or black legs like those of a spider yes
these are bus creatures with wings and
multi-jointed legs these legs aren't
just big clumsy appendages either
compared with other arthropods
scp-2086s are able to use their limbs to
perform surprisingly intricate actions
and finer levels of manipulations for
instance a number of specimens have been
observed in the wild by the scp
foundation building shelters out of any
materials that they can find near their
nesting ground and where do they
normally nest wherever there's plenty of
scrap metal and hardly any people to
notice them junkyards are the preferred
habitats of scp-2086's
and where they will normally establish
their colonies while the juveniles
remain within the confines of the colony
adult scp-2086 specimens will leave to
collect humans although on occasion the
younger specimens have been known to
travel out from their nest and rearrange
or relocate signposts for bus stops they
then place them in a route that leads
them back towards their nesting ground
it's something worth remembering if your
nearest bus stop ever seems to be a
little further away from the school than
usual afterward the older specimens will
travel along the route laid out by the
juvenile as cp 2086's picking up any
human passengers that they find waiting
at the relocated bus stops they have to
choose their moments wisely with people
boarding and disembarking from the bus
usually every few stops once an scp-2086
has as many humans on board as it can
carry with the certainty it won't lose
any at the upcoming stop it secretes a
substance similar to chloroform this
fills the inner chamber of the bus
causing that noxious smell like hospital
disinfectant the chloroform-like
substance incapacitates all the
passengers on board rendering them
unconscious and readying them to be
taken back to the local
scp-2086 colony once the adult scp-2086
has arrived at the junkyard the
juveniles will descend on it given their
much much smaller size they will climb
inside the mature specimen and forcibly
remove each and every human passenger it
is carrying within then comes the truly
nasty part feeding time each juvenile
scp-2086 will force their captive human
through an orifice that is located under
the front hood of their vehicle's shell
this sphincter a circular formation of
muscle that can expand and contract to
perform a bodily function is connected
to where the steering wheel is found on
an adult
scp-2086 the younger creatures will push
their human prey through the sphincter
consuming them once this has occurred
those hairy appendages in the driver's
seat will then latch onto the body of
the now dead human piercing through
their skin winding up and around their
bones these are the same fibrous hairs
used to puppet the deceased corpse and
use it to lure others aboard the bus but
these appendages have another function
their feeding tubes they will drain
every last drop of blood from the
scp-2086's prey until the body is little
more than a husk at which point the
tubes inject a saline solution directly
into the cadaver afterwards the inside
of the bus fills with that same
substance that preserves the corpse and
the process is complete as horrifying as
these creatures are one of the few
upsides of
scp-2086's is that they don't live very
long female specimens will reproduce
after eight days and produce 20
offspring after this point each of these
newborns reaches full maturity and size
in about a week on average
scp-2086s live for 12 to 15 days another
net positive is because of their short
life spans and scp-2086 specimen doesn't
need to feed on a human more than once
as the nutrients it absorbs as a
juvenile are enough to sustain it
through adulthood once it has matured an
scp-2086 will go out into the nearest
city or town to forage for humans
providing food to the next generation
and so the cycle continues in the future
rather than taking the bus maybe it's
safer to walk it might mean the
difference between you making it home or
becoming food now go check out the skin
stealers
scp-3333 tower and
scp-2521 redacted and infohazard as cp's
explained for more of the weirdest
anomalous monsters out there